there are six stages or modes of a
design sprint and each of these stages
solves an important part of the design
process the first phase is the
understand phase and this phase you're
trying to get clarity on the business
goals the problem you're solving for
technical feasibility the market and
user needs you've actually already been
working on some of this throughout the
first two lessons of the course and
there are other activities that you can
do which I'll cover later the second
stage is the defined stage in this stage
you might define the goal for the
product or certain features this might
include the positioning a user journey
or metrics related to the product or
those certain features we'll cover more
about metrics in Lesson four now this
stage is similar to what Richard Fulcher
was talking about when he mentioned
tasks that are related to a user's goals
for example a user may search for a
particular grocery item in our shopping
app which we then added to the cart for
purchase the third stage is the diverge
stage in this stage you want to create
as many solutions as you can to the
original design challenge and this is
the stage where you really get to
unleash your creativity it's a fun part
the fourth stage is the decide stage and
in this stage you really just want to
deliberate about the ideas that you came
up with in the previous diverged stage
refine those and then choose the best
one or some combination of the ideas so
that way you get a best possible product
the fifth stage is the prototyping stage
and this stage you want to actually
create and build the wireframes the
mock-ups or the prototypes that you'll
actually test with real users these are
the deliverables of the design sprint
and finally the last stage is the
validation stage and this stage you
really want to test your products with
real users you're testing your
wireframes you're mock-ups or your
prototypes to determine whether or not
the pipe otha sees or your risky
assumptions are true you're trying to
figure out whether or not you have the
right product and whether or not it's
usable so there you have it the six
stages of a design sprint understand
define diverge decide prototype and
throughout this lesson Aamir will
interview a design sprint master at
Google and talk more about each of these
stages
I'll follow those videos by describing
activities that you can do with each of
these stages as you watch the videos
think about which activities might be
helpful for your specific design
challenge